des leds risser bonne soirée sur public
sénat bonjour à tous dans un instant
vous allez suivre l'audition de pierre
moscovici
le ministre de l'économie a été entendu
hier soir par la commission d' enquête
sur le rôle des banques dans l'évasion
des capitaux
ce n'est pas la première commission d'
enquête sur le sujet au sénat
il y en a eu une première en 2012 qui
portait sur les phénomènes au niveau
international au niveau macroéconomique
celle ci a été fondé en avril 2013
après deux événements d'abord love
charles x
cette affaire de fuites d'informations
révélées par la presse internationale
portant sur les paradis fiscaux sur la
fraude fiscale et sur le blanchiment
d'argent
et puis les révélations sur le compte en
suisse de jérôme cahuzac et l'ancien
ministre du budget c'est donc dans ce
contexte que s'inscrit cette audition de
pierre moscovici
le ministre de l'économie très bonne
matinée sur public sénat monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs très heureux d'avoir
aujourd'hui l'occasion de parler devant
votre commission le rapporteur éric
bocquet avait déjà contribué un premier
rapport a initié le mouvement de lutte
acharnée contre la fraude et l'évasion
fiscale que nous mettons en oeuvre
désormais depuis quelques mois je dis ça
parce que vous avez compris g16 que le
gouvernement a fait de la lutte contre
la fraude fiscale une priorité de sa
politique
nous sommes dans une période de crise
économique et sociale les français sont
mis à contribution pour le redressement
du pays
la fraude qui allie l'injustice ou
sentiment d'impunité devient purement et
simplement dans ce contexte
insupportable et ça je pense que c'est
une constate pouvons faire tous ensemble
c'est ce qui détermine l'action du
gouvernement dans sa lutte contre les
paradis fiscaux
l'objectif c'est de rendre moins
attractifs ces territoires
pour resserrer l'étau contre les
fraudeurs il s'agit de développer les
moyens d'investigation pour identifier
ceux qui ne payent pas l'impôt dû il
s'agit enfin de développer les sanctions
pour ne pas les laisser impunis je parle
de ceux qui méconnaissent ou détournent
les règles vous vous interrogez de façon
plus spécifique sur le rôle des banques
dans le phénomène de lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale internationale
c'est évidemment un sujet central comme
la qualité de mise et l'économie des
finances je me propose de traiter devant
vaud à travers deux aspects principaux
la lutte contre l'opacité fiscale et le
secret bancaire d'une part la lutte
contre le blanchiment
d'autre part d'abord la lutte contre
l'opacité fiscale et le secret bancaire
en ce qui concerne ce sujet je voudrais
rappeler quelques évolutions tout à fait
décisive qui se sont déroulées ces
derniers mois sur le plan international
en rappelant que dans ce domaine c'est
ce niveau d'action qui à mon sens est
évidemment totalement décisif
un jour personnalité politique
importante il n'y a pas si longtemps
avait déclaré le secret bancaire est
terminée
c'était après le g20 de londres on a
reconnu un ancien présent la république
nicolas sarkozy
un g20 qui a donné une impulsion
décisive à ses travaux sur le plan
international mais qui n'a pas loin s'en
faut éradiquer le secret bancaire
donc je me garde pour ma part de ce type
de formule parce que je prétends que
c'est un combat acharné qu'en effet nous
sommes en passe d'emporter mais qui
demandera encore toute une série
d'efforts je comprends qu'on soit un peu
méfiant désormais lorsqu'on entend que
le monde a basculé c'est la raison pour
laquelle je suis utilisé une formule de
mon cru le secret bancaire vacille
comme il n'a jamais vacillé il reste
pousser encore ce combat je n'ai en
détail si vous le souhaitez mais je
pense qu'il faut voir en tête
qu'aujourd'hui mais c'est un fait
absolument inédit un véritable consensus
a émergé pour prendre des mesures
efficaces pour que chacun paie sa juste
part d'impôts et plus précisément
je le vois dans les réunions que je
participe le g20 au niveau ministériel
le g20 au niveau des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement le g7 et je parlerai aussi
l'union européenne et bien une idée
s'est affirmée qui est celle de la
transparence fiscale certains raillent
le fait que sans les etats-unis qui ont
mis en place cette législation dite fac
a pas de cas 24,9 ringard taxes comme
croyance at sans eux rien ne se serait
produit
bah pourquoi pas il est exact que cette
législation de 2010 qui restitue une
obligation pour les établissements
financiers étrangers de fournir aux
autorités fiscales américaines des
informations détaillées sur les pointes
bancaires détenus par les contres mais
l'américain a marqué un tournant
s'il faut s'en plaindre que ça vient des
états unis dès lors que ces sept
l'hésitation qui nous permet aujourd'hui
de demander à nos partenaires européens
et bientôt à nos partenaires du g20 je
vais revenir une information équivalente
à celle qu'ils font ni rose jean louis
cette initiative a été tout à fait
marquantes et nous ne devons pas nous en
plaindre
le fait qu'un état issu imposer à ses
partenaires il avait séparé le rapport
de force pour cela à ces bâtonnets plus
récalcitrants le principe je pense ce
mot parce qu'il est fondamental de
l'échangé automatique d'information a
permis à nos partenaires européens à ses
partenaires européens à la france en
premier lieu de porter le sujet plus
haut que jamais dans les instances
internationales et d'en faire désormais
c'est ce qui a été affirmé a si
longtemps saint pétersbourg il ya deux
semaines à l'issue de la réunion du g20
des chefs également le standard
international
par ailleurs si les évolutions
internationales sont décisives
ça ne signifie pas pour autant que nous
restions inactif sur le plan interne ou
bilatérales je suis très deux exemples
d'abord si j'ai s'agissant de nos
propres accords fatca j'espère pouvoir
le signer très prochainement avec nos
homologues secrétaire au trésor du
châtelot peut-être je l'espère lors de
ma prochaine visite à washington à
l'occasion des assemblées générales du
fonds monétaire international la banque
mondiale donc au mois d'octobre
et puis la signature la convention
succession avec la suisse au mois de
juillet dernier qui contient des
dispositions importantes en matière
d'échangé de renseignements ou encore le
projet de loi de lutte contre la fraude
qui est aujourd'hui même discuté en
seconde lecture à l'assemblée nationale
qui contient par exemple cet amendement
prévoyant d'inscrire sur notre liste
interne de paradis fiscaux tous les
états qui ont refusé de s'engager dans
le domaine de l'échangé automatique
d'informations sur ce sujet je devais
résumer ma pensée je dirais que vraiment
chaud toute une série d'impulsions ou un
faisceau concordant d'impulsion des pas
de géants ont été accomplis ces derniers
mois et j'ai le sentiment pour
participer à ces réunions
internationales et européennes qui est
quelque chose d'irréversible qui est
désormais enclenchée dans la communauté
internationale et au niveau européen
avec toujours la france comme un acteur
tout à fait important de ce mouvement
deuxième thème que je voulais évoquer
c'est la lutte contre le blanchiment
parce que les banques jouent aussi un
rôle essentiel en matière de lutte
contre le blanchiment des capitaux
celle ci a été conçu comme le moyen
d'éviter que le système bancaire et
financier ne soit le point d'entrée de
flux financiers illicites de notre
économie les obligations de vigilance
pesant sur les banques
l'obligation de déclaration auprès du
crack faim sont un élément essentiel
pour identifier ces flux et le cas
échéant identifier leurs origines et
leurs auteurs ce n'est que récemment que
la fraude fiscale est entré dans le
champ de la lutte contre le blanchiment
historiquement vous savez que c'est
plutôt le trafic de drogue et d'autres
délits de ce type qui ont servi de base
à la construction du dispositif mais au
fur et à mesure que le champ des
infractions entrant dans
l'espace du blanchiment s'élargissait
qui est devenu évident que la fraude
fiscale devait également y figurer la
france l'a prévu en 2009 dans son propre
droit puisque elle a fait partie des
pays aux côtés là encore des états unis
notamment qui a défendu son inclusion
dans les principes du gafi gaffié temps
l'organisation internationale que vous
connaissez qui coordonne la lutte contre
le blanchiment
je pense que les outils que donne notre
droit en matière de lutte contre le
blanchiment sont utiles et efficaces
pour venir appuyer la lutte que nous
menons contre la fraude fiscale est fait
il permet d'impliquer pleinement et
efficacement nos établissements
bancaires dans cette lutte
ce d'autant plus qu'ils ont c'est mon
sentiment depuis plusieurs années pris
fortement conscience de leurs
responsabilités en matière de lutte
contre le blanchiment
alors un pas supplémentaire a été
franchi lors de la loi de séparation de
régulation des activités bancaires du 26
juillet 2013 et le genre de sa
promulgation
qui est l occasion de renforcer ses
personnages et créer de nouveaux outils
qui vont permettre de renforcer encore
l'efficacité de notre lutte contre le
blanchiment notamment dans le contexte
de lutte contre la fraude fiscale et ces
dispositions là je le fus ni ont fait
l'objet pour le coup je vois ici des
sénateurs qui ont participé à ces
travaux
une approbation unanime sur tous les
bancs l'occasion de l'examen du projet
de loi
soit en première ou en seconde lecture
notamment dans le contexte de lutte
contre la fraude fiscale
la loi prévoit d'élargir le champ des
déclarations de soupçon que les banques
doivent faire à trac fin elle crée par
ailleurs une nouvelle obligation de
déclaration automatique et objective qui
ne nécessite pas nécessairement la
manifestation d'un soupçon de la part de
la banque
ce qui veut dire que les banques auront
l'obligation de transmettre à trac fin
toutes les opérations qui auront été
définis comme présentant un risque
particulier en raison par exemple de
leur pays de provenance et ou de
destination par exemple si ça vient d'un
pays non coopératifs identifiés comme
tels ou de la nature de la contrepartie
par exemple si l'opération implique un
trust ou une entité juridique de même
nature sur ce point là dans les aspects
internationaux je soulignais il ya un
instant le g20 aussi affirme sa volonté
de lutter contre les trusts d'aller
chercher d'ailleurs ces structures
opaques
quelles en sont en vérité les véritables
attributaires ou aux destinataires
ces nouveaux outils que fixer la loi
renforcera l'efficacité de l'action de
trac fait pas uniquement dans le domaine
de la fraude fiscale parce que et je
conclurai là dessus mon exposé je
souhaite qu'ils n'entretiennent pas la
confusion traque faim n'est pas une
entité chargée de lutter contre la
fraude fiscale c'est un service dédié à
la lutte contre le blanchiment
y compris en matière de foot y compris
en matière de fraude fiscale mais
également et principalement pour appuyer
l'action de la justice et des services
de police dans la lutte contre les
trafics et des lic quelle que soit leur
nature sont les éléments que je voulais
faire
connaître votre commission denquête
comme introduction et que sentiment
c'est plus qu'un sentiment c'est une
certitude et une conviction de ma part
qu'il s'agit désormais de plus en plus
d'une priorité forte dans les politiques
publiques que nous menons temps dans le
champ national qu'à l'échelle européenne
et au plan international et je le répète
j'ai le sentiment s'est fait 16 mois que
je suis mise l'économie et des finances
que on ne perd pas de temps et que des
progrès très importants sont en train
d'être enregistrées à la fois sous le
pression c'est vrai des états unis et
des acteurs fatca de l'opinion publique
et des parlementaires
il ya des choses qui sont venus
absolument intolérable elle pense que la
pression de la crise est en train de
vraiment d'ébranler
un certain nombre de vérités d'hier qui
ne sont pas des vérités de demain merci
beaucoup aux cheminées je vais passer
immédiatement la parole l'année éric
bourque et notre à porter pour les
premières questions
s'il se présente sur la liste merci de
vos propos introductif quelques quatre
questions très précises concrètes pour
lancer le débat et mes collègues ensuite
bien sûr auront des questions également
à se mettre j'aurais d'abord abordé le
point de la liste française des jeux tnc
qui vient d'être mise à jour
un peu tardivement en étonne un peu donc
dix territoires y figurent les
philippines en sont sortis îles vierges
britanniques jersey bermudes îles ont
été ajoutés je n'y vois pas la suisse je
n'y vois pas le luxembourg les bahamas
par exemple comment on expliquer en fait
la relative maigreur de cette liste
regarde d'autres lycées existant dans le
monde ce qui d'ailleurs constituer une
difficulté puisque différentes listes
existent et sont très différentes à
beaucoup d'égards
quel est votre point de vue là dessus
que ce ministre c'est une réalité qui
est évolutif j'ai moi même expliqué ce
que prévoyait la loi de séparation de
régulation des activités bancaires c'est
à dire que cette liste devait inclure
progressivement les états qui ne
pratiquent pas l'échangé automatique
d'informations en même temps nous sommes
aussi dans ce ne sera pas une course
contre la montre puisque dans le même
temps nous sommes en train d'avancer
d'avancer vers le fait que ce sont des
ça doit devenir un standard
international et que le g20 a fixé à cet
égard une date qui est la date de 2015
les critères d'aujourd'hui sont
obsolètes
ils sont appuyés sur une notion qui elle
même était une notion condé base qui est
celle d'un échange sur demande
le nouveau critère c'est l'échangé
automatique d'informations donc il faut
que les deux choses coïncide en vérité
voilà pourquoi cette liste est ainsi
établi il va de soi que au moment où
l'échangé automatique d'information
devient le standard les pays qui ne le
respecte pas et c'est écrit si je ne
m'abuse dans notre propre texte de loi à
ce moment là seront inscrits sur liste
des états non-coopératifs aux premiers
éléments de présentation du plf dont la
discussion va s'engager bientôt je crois
avoir retenu que deux milliards seraient
proviendrait de la lutte contre
l'évasion fiscale
quelles mesures particulières ont été
choisis de ce point de vue et qu'elle
cible particulière si tant est qu'il y
en ait ont été définis pour arriver à
cette somme de 2 milliards donc nous y
reviendrons dans le cadre du débat sur
le projet de financement l'occasion de
s'expliquer ici mais de manière très
claire la lutte contre la fraude est une
priorité que nous avons déjà mis en
oeuvre à travers un plan qui a porté ses
fruits puisque déjà dans le cadre du
précédent projet de loi de finances nous
avons vu s'accroître de 18 milliards 20
milliards d'euros
le produit de la lutte contre la fraude
mais je dirais que l'une des cibles
principales des nouvelles ce sera
l'optimisation fiscale à la part des
grandes entreprises et ce sont les
régulations de régularisation voilà les
chiffres et fait que je souhaitais vous
faire connaître
alors vous avez évoqué les le g20 de
saint pétersbourg il y avait tué avant
en juin le g8 en irlande du nord
alors les déclarations d'intention très
forte effectivement je partage l'idée
que le climat a changé de par le monde
est plein de raisons que vous avez cités
parmi lesquels les opinions publiques
aussi qui scintille investissent ce
terrain avec l'iss indignés qui
l'expriment qui génère aussi une
pression avec d'autres acteurs pour que
le problème soit enfin abordé mais après
ces deux jeux après ces deux sommets
donc g8 et g20
quelles mesures concrètes quant à la
mise en oeuvre ont été décidées et dans
la continuité je dire de manière qu'au
prochain sommet on ne fasse pas de même
constat mais quelles mesures concrètes
qu'elle mise en oeuvre ont été décidées
pour engager la bataille
d'abord sur ce point je veux rappeler le
point essentiel qui a été acquis lors
des discussions de tous ces derniers
mois en ce qui concerne la lutte contre
le secret bancaire c'est à dire la
promotion de l'échangé automatique
d'informations comme un standard ou de
la deûle échanges sur demande
qui en effet ne peut aboutir qu'à des
listes éthique restreinte
si on reprend les choses avec un peu de
recul moi la façon dont je les
présenterai la question de l' échange
d'informations et devenue centrale a
compté vous le rappelez du g20 de
londres en avril 2009
et c'est à ce moment là que le forum
mondial sur la transparence en matière
d'échangé d'informations fiscales
c'est transformé commencé à mener ces
évacuations sur la transparence
effective et des quelque 180 états
qu'ils composent plus exactement sur la
transparence effective permise par les
changes sur demande
c'est un travail essentiel qu'il faut
évidemment poursuivre avec la plus
grande ardeur les quasi totalité de nos
conventions bilatérales sont fondés sur
les changes sur demande
mais on sait aussi combien sont âpres
les discussions avec les partenaires
plus récalcitrants dès lors qu'il s'agit
de l'examen sur demande au cas par cas
combien conformément aux standards
internationaux
la demande doit être ciblée précise
comportaient suffisamment d'éléments
pertinents
sous peine d'être rejeté prendre un
temps souvent insupportable et donc nous
avons j'ai progressivement acquis
l'intimé conviction que l'avenir se
situe dans l'échangé automatique
d'informations s'ils sont combat que
mène gouvernement depuis plusieurs mois
en faveur de cet échange automatique
d'informations et je voulais insister je
n'ai pas fait trop dans l'introduction
mais je le fais maintenant sur le fait
que la france a été à l'impulsion et des
impulsions d'abord dans un cadre franco
allemand premières lettres en la matière
était signée par wolfgang schuble mon
blog et moi même
et puis nous avons créé un groupe dit
des cinq france allemagne royaume uni
espagne italie
je suis tout de suite par la pologne ont
tenu une conférence de presse commune
c'était en irlande lors d'un ecofin
informel dans la précédente présidence
tout ça fait que nous avons été suivis
rejoint par une majorité d'états membres
qui ont exprimé le souhait lors de
l'ecofin 14 mai du consejo plein du 22
mai 2013 de développer au sein de
l'union européenne
un système de temps d'échangé
automatique qui porterait sur le même
champ qui comportera les mêmes modalités
que celles prévues par les accords dits
fatca signé que les états unis et donc
l'idée que nous portons avec force
c'est l'idée de tout simplement d'un
fatca européen et cette idée nous le
poursuivons avec méthode
le week end dernier a eu lieu un autre
copine informel où ces sujets sont
revenus entre temps la commission a
présenté pour sa copine du 21 juin 2013
une proposition de révision de la
directive relative à la coopération
administrative dans le même fiscale pour
élargir le champ que des changes un
automatique au sein de l'union
européenne
révision qui prévoit l'obligation
d'échanger sans condition les
informations relatives aux dividendes
aux plus values aux autres revenus
financiers ainsi que les soldes des
comptes qui sont payés attribués ou
détenues par l'établissement financier
bénéfice direct ou indirect d'une
personne physique d'un autre état membre
dans le même temps et conformément à la
demande du g20 qui a réaffirmé le 6
septembre dernier c'est tout de même
très récent son engagement sur le sujet
l'os et des oeufs élabore format
d'échangé universelle fondée sur fat cas
c'est bien ça l'idée est d'ailleurs
monsieur couriat et est à vilnius avec
nous il ya trois jours et c'est ce
standard là qui doit être élaboré pour
le début 2014
keira ensuite vocation est appliquée au
sein de l'union rebelles mais aussi par
le reste du monde
nous avons insisté sur le fait qu'ils
devaient pas y avoir de différence de
standards et c'est ainsi que nous
aboutissons à l'horizon fin 2015 le 1er
janvier 2016 comme vous voulez qui a été
précisé par le g20 qu'est ce qui reste à
faire désormais nous avons déjà traduit
concrètement notre volontarisme en ce
domaine dans notre droit interne
je viens de le dire en faisant évoluer
les critères de notre liste des états ou
territoires non coopératifs
toujours avec cet horizon qui permet
l'adaptation c'est le sens de
l'amendement que j'ai fait adopter dans
le cas du projet doit sur la fraude
l'assemblée nationale qui permettra
d'inscrire à compter de 2016 la date que
la généralisation de l'échangé
automatique d'informations dans le cas
des accords fatca tout état qui ne
s'engagerait pas dans ce sens il faut
ensuite commencé d'avancer concrètement
à la fois en europe et au japon à hong
kong en soin d'éviter la création de
deux standards concurrents d'où l'idée
du standard universel
vous m'interrogez plus précis dans sur
le g20
dans le communiqué publié il est prévu
que les états doivent prendre des
mesures en matière de transparence des
personnes morales sur les sociétés les
entités juridiques comme les trusts
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle initiative
bates porté par l' ocde que nous avons
été les premiers à appuyer également
avec les allemands les britanniques les
espagnols les italiens
l'italien c'est là encore d'une autre
conférence de presse était à moscou lors
du g20 ministériel mois de mai ou juin
dernier et là nous sommes aux côtés de
l' ocde qui a traversé cette lutte
contre l'érosion des bases fiscales
promeut la transparence
un comité notamment que les états
doivent se doter d'outils comme par
exemple des registres centralisés où
sont recensés les bénéficiaires
effectifs des ces entités
la france a pris l'initiative pour
traduire rapidement cette idée dans le
droit européen dans le cadre de la 4è
directive anti blanchiment et j'ai signé
avec look un show plus d'être la semaine
dernière nous n'avons peut-être un
courrier en ce sens à michel barnier le
sujet avant désormais j'ai bon espoir
qu'on parvienne inscrite dans le droit
européen
le principe de ces registres donc nous
avançons à la fois sur le plan des
principes et sur plan des textes
législatifs qu'on prête un beignet
question de passer la parole à mes
collègues
en face de cette volonté des états quels
sont les résistances les plus fortes que
vous identifier pour avancer vers les
solutions
écoutez je le redis mon sentiment c'est
qu'il ya un mouvement politique puissant
international mondial européen qui
s'élance et qui sera irrésistible
il est exact nous sommes confrontés
sinon à la résistance - la réticence ou
si on va être très diplomate ça m'arrive
aussi aux besoins d'adaptation
un certain nombre d'états qui le secret
bancaire représente des intérêts
puissants
je voudrais signaler deux ou trois au
sein de l'union européenne ou voisins
l'union européenne où vous en doutez
dans l'union européenne l'autriche et
luxembourg
il n'y a pas de mystère à l'extérieur et
nos frontières la suisse néanmoins les
accords que nous avons passé avec la
suisse que j'ai passé avec la ministre
suisse
juste avant l'été ou encore les
discussions que nous avons au sein ou du
g20 ou bien encore de l'union européenne
montre que ces pays sont conscients de
la cité d'évoluer et quand nous parlons
de standard international je pense que
nul n'y résistera c'est pour ça que ce
temps de deux ans qui peut paraître long
est en réalité un temps extrêmement
court
si nous manifestons jusqu'au bout la
volonté avec y compris la pression
amicale qui est nécessaire pour ces pays
pour que les choses changent
effectivement oui d'ailleurs sur ce
créneau de permission vous avez évoqué
la suisse où en sommes-nous des
discussions serrées avec la suisse
n'était question dès votre arrivée
où en sommes nous aujourd'hui alors j'ai
signé avec
mon homologue madame evelyne binoche ou
convention sur les successions donkey
maintenant signée qui était signée à
paris qui fait l'objet en suisse d'un
certain nombre d' analyse et il revient
maintenant à la ministre et au conseil
fédéral qui l'a approuvé de porter ce
texte devant les instances à la fois le
conseil national si je ne m'abuse qui
est l'assemblée nationale suisse est
devant c'est peut-être plus compliqué
les cantons suisses et pour être moi
même un élu frontaliers de la suisse je
pense par exemple mes amis du jura
suisse
je ne sois pas totalement d'évidentes
mais ce texte est maintenant signer et
pour le reste sur l'échangé automatique
d'informations nous poursuivons les
débats avec la suisse avec la notion que
il faudra dans le laps de temps qui nous
sépare de la fin 2015
ce pays comme les autres se conforme à
ce standard qui je le rappelle vocation
est international donc universelle je
crois qu'il ya une prise de conscience
qui est en train de s'opérer et là
dessus le fait que ce soit le g20 tout
entier est unanime qui est pris ce
communiqué et que de surcroît ce n'est
pas été une mince affaire parce qu'il a
fallu discuter y compris des paiements
de l'union européenne une date de mise
en oeuvre soit indiquée et qu'enfin
support soit désigné c'est à dire l'oscd
de tout ça exerce je ne dirais pas une
pression mais sans y perdre août
pendant des éléments de cette tout le
monde je dis bien tout le monde doit
tenir compte
oui monsieur nice avant de donner la
parole à mes collègues j'ai juré de
question de porter tout à fait
d'ailleurs différentes l'une étant très
factuelle autres peut-être un peu plus
politique
la première je voulais vous demander
face à ce cette information que nous
avons eue par la presse face à
l'accroissement qui paraît totalement
démesurée alors que à projet de loi
devrait inciter à la prudence
cet accroissement des mesures et des des
flux des flux d'argent liquide
est ce que les flux qui ont été
constatés par les douanes et son
partance du territoire ou est ce que
c'est de l'argent qui revient et 2e 2e
partie enfin deuxième question qu'elle
est actuellement
quelles sont actuellement les
initiatives aux actions qui sont menées
par le gouvernement pour vivifier
l'harmonisation fiscale en particulier
au niveau européen puisque à l'occasion
de cette commission beaucoup de
personnes nous ont dit ce qui ne nous a
pas d'ailleurs beaucoup étonné que le
dumping fiscal qui favorisent l'évasion
et l'optimisation fiscale donc
parfaitement légale ne serait guère
combattu que lorsque nous parviendrons à
ceux à ce but certainement peu proches
que constitue l harmonisation fiscale
donc une deuxième question quelles sont
les initiatives actuelles du
gouvernement pour hâter vivifier cette
harmonisation fiscale
alors d'abord sur votre première
question c'est une augmentation des
saisies des douanes différentes beaucoup
de gens qui les commentent je connais
les résultats des manquements aux
obligations déclaratives constaté par
les douanes si pour sa demande et je
voudrais donc vous apporter toutes les
précisions auxquelles vous avez droit
ces commissions bancaires il ya
effectivement eu au premier trimestre
2013 d'une augmentation de la valeur des
infractions constatées augmentation qui
n'a pas été de l'ampleur que j'ai pu
lire puisqu'il était de 1 1% par rapport
au trimestre précédent
des chiffres qui sont très volatils en
raison et c'est ce qui explique cette
croissance d'opérations exceptionnelles
qui se sont produites ce qui compte
toutefois c'est l'interprétation comme
je le comprends de votre question sapa
semble avoir tiré de ces chiffres qui
sont des chiffres en partance
l'idée que des gens fuir est notre pays
avec des valises de billets personne ne
doit les encourager pour éviter d'être
taxé lui et qui plaît beaucoup sans
doute parce qu'elle est facile à
raconter il se trouve qu'elle est au
regard des chiffres que je vous donnais
totalement fausse garde
ces chiffres ne montrent pas d'évolution
aussi spectaculaire et d'autre part
l'évolution elle même tient notamment à
je crois une opération d'une ampleur
exceptionnelle
je rappelle d'ailleurs que ces fraudeurs
pourrait échapper au dispositif musclé
poursuite que nous mettons en place
depuis un an au niveau international et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut encore avancé
l'échangé automatique d'informations qui
à terme rendre à ces mouvements démunis
tout intérêt
donc on voit le lien avec le général de
votre commission d' enquête sur une
harmonisation fiscale en europe alors
c'est un sujet sur lequel la france a
history historiquement une position très
très favorable la différence de la
fiscalité indirecte notamment de la tva
la fiscalité directe des entreprises
restent encore peu harmoniser donc
soumise à la règle de l'unanimité
il ya deux domaines qui sont en réalité
si on exclut la tva les assises ce cas
il faut avancer c'est l'assistance
administrative entre états membres à
travers trois directives la directive
sur la coopération administrative en
matière fiscale
la directive sur la fiscalité de
l'épargné la directive sur l'assistance
administrative en matière de
recouvrement des créances fiscales
et puis l'élimination des risques
doubles impositions en matière de
fiscalité d'entreprise
après la directive merci intérieur de
vence et fusion comment agit la france
dans ce contexte d'abord nous promouvons
auprès de nos partenaires l'incitent
l'uteq plus d'efficacité contre le
phénomène d'érosion des bases fiscales
et les transferts de profits donc ces
initiatives bex le plan d'action du peps
de ces dieux que j'évoquais il ya
quelques minutes
et dans ce contexte le conseil européen
à l'initiative de la france a demandé à
l'union européenne de prendre pleinement
part à ces travaux est de proposer les
solutions y compris par voie
d'harmonisation législative et
continuons à promouvoir cette thèse
et puis et puis
la france a demandé à la commission de
réfléchir spécifiquement la fiscalité du
numérique et ce sujet devrait être à
l'ordre du jour du conseil européen en
octobre prochain conseil européen
extraordinaire
enfin la france continue de soutenir le
projet d'assiette commune à l'impôt sur
les sociétés c'est la directive dite
axis dans la mesure où une telle
harmonisation conduire à simplifier la
vie des entreprises et apporter un
remède à la concurrence fiscale
c'est un projet évidemment très
ambitieux et je ne cache pas que j'ai le
sentiment qu'un accord de tous les états
membres sera assez difficile à obtenir
merci beaucoup je vais maintenant
essayer parole à notre collègue des
mines man qui j'aurai monsieur chiron le
chocolat madame goulet nominale mais ce
président monsieur le ministre
en effet votre gouvernement a engagé
beaucoup d'initiatives pour lutter
contre la fraude et l'évasion fiscale
est en effet sur l'automaticité des
transferts d'informations est ce qui
serait pas envisageable quand même de
pousser un peu plus loin la logique en
essayant de faire comme en instaurant un
système comparable à celui des états
unis qui est pas simplement
l'automaticité des informations mais le
droit de suite c'est en instaurant un
droit de suite en france sur les impôts
est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas plus de
possibilité d'obtenir l'automaticité de
la démarche et comment expliquez vous
que les etats unis puissent ils ont fait
un système comparable
comment expliquez vous que l'europe ne
le fasse pas ou en tout cas quelles
pourraient être les handicaps pour que
l'europe le fasse et à défaut de
l'europe la france
deuxième sujet la taxation des
transactions financières vous
parait-elle un outil pertinent pour
mieux regarder ces transactions donc
pour éviter un certain nombre d'évasions
fiscales
est-ce que vous pensez que c'était un
outil supplémentaire au delà de l'autre
fonction qui est qui est sa fonction de
justice de prélèvement sur ces
transactions
troisièmement on a eu pas mal de
l'audition qui montre que dès qu'une
bande et qu'on fait nouvelle loi il ya
les spécialistes dans le système
bancaire international et en particulier
les banques qui veulent aider leurs
clients à contourner à leur banque ou
officines qui veulent essayer de
contourner les nouvelles législations
on voit bien qu'il ya toute une
spécialisation utilisation de
l'informatique et c est ce qu on avait
des russes débat sur la loi quels sont
les outils que le ministère des finances
a pour essayer d'avoir cette espèce de
dix paires et activités créatrices sur
anticiper les fraudes les méthodes
informatiques et autres
et qu'est ce qui est des liens qui sont
organisées avec la justice les services
de renseignement parce que on sait que
ce genre de chose mérite quand même un
certain nombre d'efforts de
renseignements je termine sur un sujet
que j'ai découvert récemment qui est
celui de les banques qui elles mêmes
bénéficient de grands avantages fiscaux
quand elles et elles sont censées avoir
subi une fraude en l'occurrence j'ai
découvert cette affaire à travers ce que
prétend la défense de monsieur kerviel
sur le fait que la société générale
aurait bénéficié d'une allègement fiscal
de 1 milliard sept que a jusqu'à ce jour
il semble que l'arrêt du conseil d'état
donne quelques critères pour permettre
cette pseudo hannache fiscale qui est
d'une part qu'il n'y ait pas de
collusion dans le dans la direction de
la banque deuxièmement que les méthodes
de contrôle a été optimale et n'ait pas
fait l'objet de faiblesse et
troisièmement évidemment après se pose
de questions de caumont mesure quelle
est l'ampleur de la réalité de la fraude
dire en clair est-ce qu'on gonfle pas un
peu la mule pour
essayer de bénéficier des avantages
fiscaux donc est ce que vous considérez
qu'aujourd'hui ou de lettres cette
affaire sur lequel je vous ai interrogé
par courrier
est ce que vous pensez qu'il serait pas
judicieux d'avoir une législation
peut-être qu'ils cadrent mieux parce que
bon les aides les avantages fiscaux
donnés aux banques elles mêmes
quand elles prétendent avoir subi des
fraudes le ministe le voulez vous je
demande à voir mes collègues s'il y a
des questions qui seraient dans le même
environnement signe non eh bien on va
commencer par celle là
bien alors sur le droit de suite ça fait
partie des réflexions en cours notamment
sur la territorialité avec un petit
problème qui est que les conventions de
territoriale bilatérales pendant qu'ils
s'y opposer que nous avons près de 120
et donc nous avons là une difficulté
c'est l'impôt sur les contribuables qui
ne résident pas en france dont il s'agit
et ses suppôts de s'écarter de nos
principes légaux dont convention avec
une application qui est très lourde il
faut être bien au clair sur l'objectif
d'une telle réforme peut-être
pourrez-vous y réfléchir dans le cas de
vos préconisations sur sa d habiter je
crois que l'enjeu de l'échangé
automatique d'informations c'est d'abord
d'appliquer l'agitation sur nos
contribuables ses actuels deuxièmement
sur la taxe sur les transactions
financières si votre question parce que
c'est un projet que nous soutenons forme
fortement la mine man très fortement
là encore c'est une initiative franco
allemande et celle européenne
tout est parti parce que nous donnerons
les élections allemand nous verrons bien
d'une lettre que j'ai signé là encore
avec paul quin de chambre et puis c'est
ensemble que nous avons réussi regroupé
un nombre de signataires qui nous a
permis de présenter une coopération
renforcée maintenant il ya trail de la
commission travail de qualité travail ce
qu'elle nous réfléchissons aussi que
nous ne prenons pas dans son intégralité
pour les raisons qui ont des raisons
diverses
une d'entre elles étant que en tant que
miss de l'économie et des finances
français je tiens à ce que nous
puissions conserver une place financière
européenne continental
je parle d' euronext donc je ne souhaite
pas non plus et tout le monde n'est pas
dans cette situation en europe
affaiblir notre propre base en la
matière qui est un élément je tiens à
votre attention de souveraineté qui
n'est pas négligeable
néanmoins la taxe sur les transactions
financières verra le jour
elle sera beaucoup plus substantiel que
si qui existent aujourd'hui elle portera
sur un grand nombre de produits portent
notamment certains dérivés puisque c'est
ça qui est en cause et nous poursuivons
les discussions techniques
j'ai pu lire ici ou là à partir de ces
vrais expression que j'ai pu avoir moi
même et que je ne renie pas la sensation
que le gouvernement français renonce et
n'ont en rien du tout pas en quoi que ce
soit mais nous cherchons à faire une
taxe des transactions financières qu'ils
soient justement calibré et qui
n'ébranle pas aussi ces éléments de
souveraineté que j'expliquais alors
l'application à champ large du pays le
plus large possible permet d'éviter ou
de limiter les contournements c'est vrai
mais je ne pense pas pour être en toute
rigueur intellectuelle qu'on puisse dire
que ce soit un outil de lutte contre la
fraude ça peut être un résultat dont
quelque sorte un direct mais ce n'est
pas quelque chose de direct sur
la façon de trouver la fraude nous
réfléchissons à inclure les services de
recherche d'administration fiscale au
sein de ce qu'on appelle la communauté
du renseignement en france pour le reste
j'ai déjà de très nombreux échanges
formels et informels avec des forces de
police et les autorités judiciaires
mais ce que vous soulevez c'est un
problème qui est un problème plus vaste
plus large depuis je suis midi aucune
différence j'ai eu l'occasion de rendre
visite à un grand nombre de services
ça ne le dg fip et c'est vrai que cette
course c'est à dire à la fois juridique
et technologique entre les fraudeurs et
l'administration
c'est un sujet de préoccupation tous les
jours et je profite d'être devant vous
pour rendre hommage l'exceptionnelle
qualité de notre administration fiscale
en la matière j'ai eu l'occasion de
faire présenter un certain nombre de cas
c'est un conte nous est dure à pantin et
franchement devant des gens qui sont
motivés doué qui ne se laisse pas faire
le doute est passé ils sont assez
nombreux
madame dumas donc quand même 120 mille
personnes
dg fip si derrière ça vous soulever
d'autres questions budgétaires seraient
que ministère des finances est un
ministère qui contribue à l'effort qui
est demandé aux administrations
publiques qui sera plus important encore
pour cette année puisque ne renouvelant
pas de 1350 emplois dont 1 à un peu
moins de 2000 à la dgesip que nous
faisons avec un projet stratégique qui
est piloté par le directeur juridique
science publique et que les effectifs de
vérificateurs puisque c'est adresser y
sont eux sanctuariser parce que à
l'intérieur même de l'organisation de
cette direction il ya des priorités
encore une fois ça se fait à partir d'un
plan stratégique que j'ai à dire c'est
pas une entreprise mais on a un dialogue
avec les agents qui permet au fur et à
mesure que les effectifs doivent
s'adapter de moderniser le service
public avec très clairement des axes qui
sont partis alors pour ce qui est de la
faire
kerviel je dirais j'ai reçu votre
courrier
je vous répondrai il s'agit d'un sujet
qui porte sur une période qui précède
vont arriver je vais m'efforcer de vous
apporter une réponse la plus rapide
possible avec deux petites difficultés
quand même qui n'échappera à personne
qui s'appelle le secret fiscal
lorsque vous en dire le plus possible
madame lienemann messieurs vont
connaître chéron oui monsieur le
ministre
oui on la foule avait remarques vous
l'avait dit et puis mes collègues aussi
on s'aperçoit que l'attitude des états
aujourd'hui change très vite et la
volonté de lutter contre l'évasion est
très forte
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure de la
taxation des des multinationales et
notamment celles s'allumer numérique qui
aujourd'hui aisément se soustrait à
l'impôt
on n'a pas quand on nous avons reçu ici
le directeur de l' ocde
on avait évoqué le fait que on a cherché
à faire en sorte qu'ils aient pas de
double imposition mais on est passé à la
double non d'imposition c'est le cas de
le dire avec d'ailleurs des des états au
niveau de l'europe qui ont facilité je
dirais 7,7 double non non imposition
quand on regarde ce qui se passe au
niveau du luxembourg rundel l'irlande
est-ce que alors j'ai on a on a entendu
que le g20 était été et c'était je veux
dire avait envie de suivre les
recommence les recommandations de lancer
des oeufs alors j'ai envie de dire est
ce que cela passe va se faire assez
rapidement parce qu'il y a ça représente
des sommes assez considérable dans les
recettes fiscales de nos états et puis
est ce que au niveau de l'europe
justement on peut agir plus vite
puisqu'on a deux et a quand même qui
sont concernés deux états qui ont la
même monnaie que que nous tous en bus
donc ils affaiblissent en affaiblissant
les états
de l'eurogroupe il affaiblit la femis
leur propre monnaie
d'une certaine façon qu'est ce qu'il ya
est ce qu'on peut penser que ça réagir
assez rapidement au moins au niveau de
l'eurogroupe et au niveau de l'europe
madame cool et il me dit que ces
questions sont dans le même thème oui
c'est pas très éloignée en plus monsieur
le ministre je dois quitter cette
audition dans cinq ou six minutes
merci monsieur le président oui j'ai une
petite question relative aux conventions
internationales parce qu'on a eues ici
un débat très intéressant sur
l'efficacité nos conventions
internationales est ce qu éventuellement
vous avez un service qui envisageraient
de revoir un certain nombre de
conventions fiscales qui parfois
ressemble à un sketch de coluche à dire
plus tu peux payer moins tu payes en
gros je pense à la convention qui nous
lie au qatar qui fait de la france un
paradis fiscal ce n'est quand même pas
tout à fait l'objectif avec des gens qui
sont capables
bien qu'ils investissent beaucoup de
contribuer un peu et ma deuxième
question c'est est ce qu'il n'ya pas une
très grande hypocrisie dans la fin des
paradis fiscaux on sait notamment qu'en
matière de défense et d'armement
nos principales sociétés utilisent ces
paradis fiscaux comme toutes les autres
sociétés du monde pour pouvoir effectuer
des transactions et soutenir notre notre
industrie de l'armement je l'en remercie
alors d'abord sur la question du
numérique
nous avons été les premiers à porter ce
sujet d'abord lors du conseil européen
d'octobre
nous avons obtenu que ce sujet soit
évoqué dans le cas de l'initiative peps
et puis aussi au g20 nous avons beaucoup
plaidé pour que ce soit là aussi un plus
dans le champ des conclusions et du
communiqué du g20 et c'est la france qui
a porté ce thème peut-on agir plus vite
ce thème sera abordé régulièrement au
g20 et un conseil national du numérique
traduit ces négligences au plan interne
je crois que nous devons tout de même en
la matière car des en tête que tout cela
s'inscrit dans le même calendrier
encore une fois ce calendrier je pense
qu'il est mon passage mais raisonnable
et puis honnête notre part de dire que
c'est bien la fin de l'année 2015 qui
est concerné ce qui veut dire que nous
allons travailler à la consolidation du
fatah européens que nous allons
travailler à la confection du standard
ocde comme avait reçu le goya ici et
puis que nous allons ensuite travaillé
l'application de tout ça s'agissant des
eaux internationales
ce sont des questions qui ont déjà
déposé sur la convention signée par nous
connaissent et ce en 2007 première est
d'être signalé signés par les précédents
prison la république
c'est vrai que c'est pas la moins
généraux de nos conventions c'est pas
pour autant un modèle on peut sans doute
envisager de la rue discuter pour le
reste sa liste des paradis fiscaux
on a eu ce débat dans le cadre de la loi
bancaire et l'idée n'a pas été par
exemple d'interdire nos banques d'agir
dans les paradis fiscaux
certains groupes politiques pouvaient
souhaiter qu'on agisse dans ce sens
l'idée c'est autre chose c'est de
connaître l'activité des banques dans
les paradis fiscaux pour arriver à
déceler s'il y a justement des flux ou
des évolutions qui sont de normal d'où
un besoin de connaissances et
d'informations
c'est la démarche que nous absolument
mais déjà c'est bien cette démarche là
que nous avons suivi parce que bon il ya
aussi des réalités économiques
industrielles de défense vous avez
évoqué ce qu'il ce dont il faut se
prévenir c'est justement de dévolution
qui elle-même traduirait des flux
illicites ou bien des mouvements qui
sont des mouvements anormaux
quant au travail sur les conventions
fiscales
la révision des conventions pour lutter
contre les abus est une priorité
bon je citerai mon collègue ben ammar
cazenobe sais pas si la livre vous mais
le qatar est un précédent qui ne se
reproduira pas ici nous travaillons
beaucoup en europe et la convention
succession avec la suisse s'inscrit bien
dans cette idée de revoir les
conventions en vigueur ici nos amis
suisses ont accepté de le faire c'est
parce qu'il mesurait aussi qu'ils
avaient désormais cette pression
l'évolution qui s'exerce et qu'on peut
pas garder un droit obsolète qui n'est
plus du tout en conformité avec les
standards d'aujourd'hui chez colas merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre merci de vous éclairer de vos
réponses d'éclairer la commission d'
enquête sur ce sujet qui nous préoccupe
et nous vous donnons acte vous êtes
beaucoup mobilisés sur ce front
néanmoins un problème apparaît celui de
la faible quantité des poursuites pour
fraude fiscale et l'impression peut-être
d'impunité des plus gros fraudeurs
c'est en tout cas une impression la
répression pénale de la froide vous
semble-t-elle suffisante
vous savez que le verrou de bercy sur ce
point nous pose le problème
deuxième question lors de nos
précédentes auditions il a été suggéré
qu'il faudrait au minimum 25 ans pour
procéder aux opérations de
régularisation prévu par la sécu
circulaire du 25 juin 2013 juge pas la
date exacte aux moyens actuellement
dégagé
pouvez vous vous rappelez ces moyennes
et nous indiquait monsieur le ministre
ce qui sera fait pour les mettre à
niveau là le les deux questions que je
souhaitais vous posez en vous remerciant
une réponse passe
comme j'ai procédé tout à l'heure je
vais demander à philippe dominati de
poser cette question qui doit être un
peu aussi dans la même zone
monsieur le ministre au cours de la
précédente commission denquête nous
avons eu des difficultés ainsi que les
autorités françaises à établir la masse
de la fraude fiscale et on avait été
étonné de l'absence d'instruments de
mesure je dirais particulièrement fiable
par bercy de pouvoir évaluer ce
potentiel
aujourd'hui compte tenu de cette
dynamique est enclenchée
tout ce que vous avez fait est ce que
vous êtes en mesure de nous dire qu'est
ce qu'il en est exactement que pour vous
quel est le montant de la fraude fiscale
en france à l'heure actuelle
maintenant au bout de deux exercices je
dirai où il ya une vigueur constante
dans ce domaine le chimiste idée des
poursuites je prononcerai pas table
faible quantité mais peut mieux faire
sans doute monsieur le sénateur cola est
précisément c'est tout l'objet du projet
de lutte contre la fraude fiscale qui
est de durcir les sanctions
et puis aussi de donner davantage de
pouvoirs aussi bien la justice que cas
d'administration et donc je vous invite
à vous inscrire dans ce mouvement je
pense que nous avons là un projet qui
est un projet bienfaits dont le grès
précis et de nous donner davantage
d'armes
une direction parieurs du contrôle dnf
la dnvsf a mis en place un service
dédiée composée de vingt et un jean pour
l'instant qu'à 100 dossiers ont été
déposés
je peux vous assurer qu'il ne faudra pas
à 25 ans pour les traiter enfin
s'agissant du montant de fraude fiscale
j'irai presque par définition monsieur
le sénateur nominative tous les chiffres
sont erronés
parce que nous n'avons pas connaissance
presque par définition une fraude peut
être évalué ne pas être connu alors ce
que ce que il ya un chiffre qui circule
beaucoup qui est un chai de 50 à 60
milliards d'euros qui est un chiffre
d'origine syndicale du syndicat qui
d'ailleurs ne sont pas forcément les
plus mal informés mais c'est très
difficile à mesurer
du travaux en cours sur la tva par
exemple montrent que nous avons à peu
près 10 milliards d'euros de fraude à
des cas ce qui est tout de même très
significatif j'étais hier dans le cher
avec un député monsieur yann galut qui
travaillent sur ce sujet je pense que
c'est en effet jeu de tout à fait
prioritaire sur l'impôt sur les sociétés
nous sommes à peu près sur le même ordre
de grandeur
disons que tout ça peut être évaluée
mais n'est pas vraiment vérifiable par
les services mais nous sommes quand même
demandé chiffres qui sont extrêmement
significatif sans aucun doute oui c'est
évidemment les prélèvements ont évoqué
pas les bases plus seulement que
gagnez-vous d'accord je vais redonner la
parole à eric bocquet pour les dernières
questions de cette fin d'après midi 13
victoires et précédé d'une soirée vous
avez raison alors juste une remarque
incidence sur la qualité
l'administration fiscale française
nous serons nous sommes tous convaincus
il pourra constater dans les auditions
puis dans le travail qu il éxécuté et
j'en veux la meilleure preuve
l'engouement des banques a recruté dans
la haute administration fiscale
française les meilleurs de leurs agents
conseiller en fiscalité
donc ça c'est la meilleure preuve à mon
avis de leurs connaissances de leurs
compétences et de leur savoir faire mais
ça c'est une remarque incidente
que vous inspire monsieur le ministre la
présence très considérable des banques
françaises dans les paradis fiscaux
alors s'agissant de l'administration
fiscale je me permettre avec beaucoup de
respect peut-être d'une formule et les
choses différemment sans doute recruter
de bons mais les meilleurs restent à
l'administration fiscale
ça j'en suis absolument persuadé ce sont
ceux qui est en un sens civique en effet
un sens du service public je ne dis pas
que les autres sont à blâmer
enfin je n'ai pas senti pour ma part
d'affaiblissement du qualité de cette de
la qualité de cette administration
salissant de nos banques dans les
paradis fiscaux j'ai commencé répond il
ya quelques instants sur le fait que
nous souhaitions à travers la loi
séparation bancaire faire la
transparence davantage sur ses activités
c'est sans doute une problématique qui
nous a non pas séparé mais sur lequel
nous avons été amis discuté lors du
projet de loi
autrement dit quelle doit être la part
de moralisation et quelle doit être la
part de palma tisme et en tant que mise
et finance je dois être porteur volonté
tic qui est obligé par les
parlementaires et aussi d'une forme de
pragmatisme je m'en explique
j'ai eu l'occasion de dire à plusieurs
reprises à quel point des activités
devaient être prohibé quand elle était
nécessaire que le soin que vous êtes
connu que la transparence soit faite et
c'est l'esprit de la loi bancaire et en
même temps que nous ne devions pas
désarmer la compétitivité de notre
système bancaire
c'est une industrie la banque qui
emploie 400 mille personnes nous avons
des banques dont la chance d'avoir des
banques sont des banques solides sur le
plan systémique vous savez que nous
allons dans le cadre de l'union bancaire
lancé ce qu'on appelle les stress tests
pour évaluer si tu es sur le banc que
j'ai pas d'inquiétude à ce sujet là
elles doivent aussi être capable
2 d'offrir à leurs clients une série
d'opérations financières qui elle est
mais au niveau de leurs concurrents et
dans beaucoup d'opérations financières
c'est peut-être du côté du client il
faut se tourner et pas seulement du côté
de la banque
la présence dans certains pays est une
exigence vers les banques mais bien sûr
ça ne justifie pas tout de l'exercice de
transparence auquel le web bancaire les
les astreint certains pays comme les
bermudes accueil par exemple des
sociétés des captives d'assurance de
grands groupes pour servir ses clients
les banques doivent assurer représentant
ce pays
je pense qu'il foulera coup sûr à mesure
que une progression de l'application de
la loi
capable de faire le départ entre ce qui
est nécessaire c'est qui est
injustifiable
je vous dire que nous ne baissons pas la
garde dès lors que le pays en question
ne se montre pas coopératif et c'est
pourquoi par exemple ils sont des
bermudes on a inscrit ce pays pour le
coup dans notre propre liste et ont
finalement tout ramène à la même chose
c'est-à-dire un échange automatique
d'informations parce que je suis
persuadé que le passage aux dits
standards et encore une fois le temps
peut sembler long moralité ça ira très
vite
la sphère de deux ans maintenant d'une
grosse année
nous permettra d'élargir la liste des
territoires coopératives non coopératifs
et du coup d'être beaucoup plus
d'effectifs dans la lutte contre les
phénomènes qui vous mobilise avec les
deux dernières questions d'eric boké et
votre réponse nous tiendrons juste dans
leur édition mais ils subissent ont
évoqué le cas de monsieur kerviel je me
permets de révoquer non pas pour
m'acharner sur cette situation
particulière est quand même assez
emblématique de ce que la finance est
devenue ces dernières années
évidemment la banque pour laquelle
travailler en gros liquide les comptes
en faisant porter le chapeau
en gros à cette personne mais est-ce
qu'on peut pas quand même s'interroger
sur la situation d'une banque et les
dirigeants la responsabilité dirigeant
d'une banque qui annonce un héros se
prend pas ce terme technique de l'ordre
de 20% qui ne sont pas atteignables cent
des prises de risques excessifs
considérable et qu'on a pu mesurer de
par le monde
quel est votre point de vue là-dessus
j'ai dit qu'il s'agissait d'une affaire
qui s'était déroulé dans un temps où je
n'étais pas mis l'économie et des
finances mais qui évidemment a
interpellé qui doit susciter des
réponses se bat simplement pourrait
souligner qaîda plupart des aspects type
secret fiscal je vais prendre mon ami de
man qui a aussi tout même des procédures
judiciaires qui sont en cours qui font
que on comprendra que je puisse peut
exprimer sur ce cas précis mais je vous
avoue répondre à partir de la loi
bancaire
parce que c'est ça qui nous préoccupe et
maintenant c'est justement en quoi les
choses changent d'abord la rentabilité
des banques n'est plus la même
les risques ne sont plus les mêmes
aujourd'hui deuxièmement dans la
séparation de régulation des activités
bancaires nous avons considérablement
durci l'aspect contrôle prudentiel et
résolution
en introduisant un principe qui est le
principe qu'il faut paye alors je parle
pas pour le coup spécifiquement de l'
affaire kerviel mais imaginons de
défaillance d'une banque par telle ou
telle opération
jusqu'à présent on sait qui est amené à
payer
c'est ce sont les déposants qui peuvent
qu'y rist supporter les choses la banque
la loi manque à inverser cette logique
puisque désormais ce sont les
actionnaires et les dirigeants qui sont
concernés et les pouvoirs de l'autorité
de contrôle prudentiel résolution vont
jusqu'à vous le savez donner le pouvoir
de démettre dirigeants de banques qui
ont été responsables d'errements qui
pourrait conduire à ladite résolution
par ailleurs nous avons progressé dans
le cas de la bancaire dans la définition
d'outils pour éviter que l'écart type
qui à bien notre produit je pense au
contrôle des traders est dantesque de
trading j'ose espérer qu'avec les autres
nous sommes donnée noté ce type de fer
est derrière nous sur celle là je ne
peux pas me ronge le montre la dernière
question à danser alors pour revenir aux
banques suisses cap et d'actions vous
inspirent les initiatives de banquiers
suisses dans la dernière période qui
demandent à leurs clients de présenter
des garanties de conformité fiscale
mais ce genre de saut dans la dernière
période de la part de certains
établissements bancaires suisses
voilà on demande en gros des comptes aux
clients etes-vous clinton hirsch et moi
pour faire court
bah je pense que c'est un signe monsieur
le député monsieur le sénateur des
sénateurs jeu tout le respect que j'ai
c'est à dire que c'est un signe que le
secret bancaire vacille que les choses
changent et que les banques suisses
commencent à prêter attention à leur
réputation est au fond le travail que
nous faisons dans les gouvernements à
l'échelle internationale à l'échelle
européenne
le travail que vous faites parlementaire
la pression de l'international la
pression de l'opinion tout ça concourt
dans la même direction c'est à dire à
faire en sorte que dans et compris les
citadelles traditionnelle du secret
bancaire en fasse beaucoup plus
attention beaucoup plus attention
aujourd'hui et qu'on évite à sa rente de
situation qu'on a pu connaître ici ou là
et donc comment vous dire je trouve ça
plutôt bien mais c'est un signe
d'évolution positive qui me laissent à
penser qu'il faut sortir aussi non pas
des caricatures elles peuvent exister
mais de l'idée que ces choses vont
continuer pour toujours non ne
continuera pas pour toujours et je le
répète moi j'ai cette conviction n'était
pas qu'une conviction parce qu'il faudra
être vigilant réactif et proactif que je
lui dit dans le secret bancaire va s'y
est qu un processus irréversible mettra
fin
ces formes actuelles et qu aucun pays ne
pourra résister à ce processus
aucun et le comportement des banques
suisses et sans doute déjà début
d'anticipation comme la signature de
conventions succession du fait que ce
pays comme les autres va se mettre en
conformité que ce droit nouveau que nous
sommes en train d'élaborer l'échelle
internationale et bien matthew nous vous
remerciant des réponses que vous allez
apporter à notre commission et mesdames
messieurs nous vous remercions de votre
présence lors de cette audition
c'est une chose dont je vois pour tom
dobbs et messieurs de sénateur voilà
pour cette audition de pierre moscovici
le ministre de l'économie qui est
intervenu notamment pour dire
l'importance des échanges automatiques
d'informations pour résoudre le problème
de l'évasion fiscale en europe tout de
suite retour à une audition qui a eu
lieu la semaine dernière au sénat
une audition tenue par la commission des
lois et qui portait sur le non cumul des
mandats constitutionnaliste et
professeurs de droit ont participé à une
table ronde sur le sujet je vous
rappelle qu'ici c'est un sujet très
sensible
l'atmosphère est électrique aujourd'hui
alors que le non cumul des mandats doit
arriver cet après midi en séance
publique
mais tout de suite retour à cette
audition de la semaine dernière je
voulais simplement pour commencer et
constater moi mais la surprise en été
frappée le regarde en lisant les
documents de l'assemblée nationale de
voir que le le le rapport sur eux
les deux projets qui nous réunissent
aujourd'hui que ce rapport insiste et
très long moment et comme commencer par
cette question et qu'il laquelle il
attachait beaucoup d'importance de la
spécificité française qu'il conviendrait
d'éradiquer et j'ai réagi en me disant
mais c'est un argument qui est
hasardeuse parce que en fait de
spécificité française
il en est d'autres et qui sont
singulièrement plus spectaculaire
et je voudrais plus problématique
elle ne serait à commencer par le
président de la république si on le
compare à ses homologues étrangers et la
concentration du pouvoir qui caractérise
actuellement le plus un certain temps
déjà le régime et demi que les réformes
de 2000 et 2001 du quesnay du calendrier
électoral aux 105 millièmes ans aggravée
je pense qu'en 2000 2001 quand on a voté
ses réformes
on aurait pu se préoccuper de ce que
l'on commence à découvrir aujourd'hui
c'est simplement une remarque qui vaut
aussi pour d'autres réformes
le corollaire de cette concentration du
pouvoir a été sur le plan parlementaire
une sorte de caporalisation qui est
aussi enfants droit comparé et une
certaine spécificité française suffit de
penser imaginer que l'assemblée
nationale sur la b2 l'occasion et est à
voter sur le même sujet que la chambre
des communes et qu'elle est émis un vote
négatif comme les communes le 29 août
pour imaginer l'impression de du crime
de lèse majesté que cela aurait produit
orlov les projets qui qui nous amène
aujourd'hui ici le projet adopté le
projet adopté par l'assemblée nationale
s'inscrivent dans cette logique de
concentration du pouvoir dans la mesure
où à côté des bénéfices escomptés sur
lesquelles je ne reviens pas elle
aboutit tas a privé les députés d'une
assise territoriale personnel et par
conséquent à réduire leur indépendance
pour les soumettre davantage encore